[Musica]
don albero
che questo disegno qui è nato
misticamente
in un momento in cui non riuscivo a
stare in equilibrio con il tronco sulla
sedia
eppure da un punto di vista
tematico
compositivo
anche tecnico se vogliamo il disegno che
più mi rappresenta
infatti da un punto di vista tematico
indaga
la radice
che un tema a me molto molto caro perché
la radice c pianta bene per terra però è
anche la base della nostra evoluzione
del nostro cambiamento
la radice
ci fa
avvertire un senso di appartenenza
neanche
ci apre all'altro ci pianta bene in un
luogo ma anche
la base per aprirci ed espanderci verso
le cose che vogliamo raccogliere e
cogliere
da un punto di vista compositivo
da un albero
rappresenta anche molto bene la mia
percezione spaziale e da un punto di
vista tecnico è stato realizzato con
una fascetta che inserisco
sulla mia mano destra ed entro cui
inserisco diverse ausili ed è ad oggi è
il metodo dello strumento che mi
permette di disegnare dipingere
molto spesso mi sono chiesta che cosa mi
avesse guidato nell'ideazione nella
realizzazione di questo disegno qua e
devo dire che dopo un po di tempo mi è
stato assolutamente chiaro
si tratta del desiderio
infatti il desiderio ci impone in un
atteggiamento attivo propositivo nei
confronti della vita e genera sempre una
energia vitale e creativa
molto tempo fa una ragazza mi definì
macchina desiderante
e anche se teorizzata da filosofi e
intellettuali
io per lungo tempo ho ritenuto molto
paradossale
associare al alla macchina
il concetto di desiderio
solo più tardi sono riuscita a
visualizzare quanto il desiderio si
possa tradurre in energia necessaria a
far funzionare un
tutte le componenti di un sistema
in questo senso infatti secondo me il
desiderio contiene proprio lei l'idea di
spostamento di movimento e per lungo
tempo da buona macchina desiderante ho
percorso lo spazio anche noi
praticamente se vogliamo senza mai
immaginare che si potesse fare
esperienza dello spazio senza
coinvolgere piedi e gambe e invece è
proprio grazie a questa mia necessità di
realizzare
che oggi ho capito che l'idea
del desiderio sicuramente coinvolge il
lo spostamento del movimento ma più che
altro desiderio
a che fare con una propensione della
mente perché attiva tutto un turbine di
idee che
coinvolge persone occasioni il maestro
gianni rodari
rende manifesta la connessione tra
vitalità e desiderio
infatti secondo lui
il non desiderare a partire solamente a
essere inanimati come i sassi e dice che
sono i sassi non desiderano nulla
vogliono solamente rimanere sassi e non
sanno neanche di palermo
per me il desiderio è anche un atto di
fede perché in un certo senso
è come se percepissimo che
abbiamo delle potenzialità
in un certo senso per percepiamo anche
che il mondo gli altri sono pronti ad
accoglierle queste nostre potenzialità
il desiderio quindi diventa una sorta di
promessa che noi facciamo a noi stessi e
agli altri e che ci guida questa
promessa guida la nostra vita
determinando
le città dove vivremo le nostre
relazioni e tutte le occasioni
e proprio
nei momenti di totale stravolgimento
della nostra esistenza infatti che il
desiderio
ci fa rimanere fedele a noi stessi e
quindi anche se la forma se la nostra
forma cambia totalmente
a volte anche in maniera irrimediabile
cambierà la nostra routine
cambia la nostra quotidianità il
desiderio ci fa percepire quella radice
profondissima
ci consente di di riconoscerci e
e quindi il nostro viaggio continua
anche sotto la nostra diversa forma e in
questo senso il desiderio è
profondamente legato alla nostra
identità
un'altra cosa che amo moltissimo del
desiderio è che persona tura ci rende
assolutamente uguali perché tutti noi
desideriamo
però allo stesso tempo ci rende
completamente diversi perché ognuno di
noi è un desiderio differente ma
soprattutto differente è
sono le differenti sono le strategie che
poi metteremo in atto per raggiungere
quei desideri
mi piace moltissimo pensare al mondo
come una catena infinita di desideri che
possono essere visti come contributi
in questo senso possiamo vedere questi
contributi come legate al grandissimo
progresso che
potrebbe interessare la nostra società
le lesioni midollari
in particolare la lesione midollare
cervicale che mi ha interessato
rendendomi tetraplegiche quindi
paralizzando i miei quattro alti
e ha fatto percepire
profondissimamente quanto il desiderio
sia curativo identitario trainante
e quindi il desiderio di espressione
creative artistica che ha sempre guidato
la mia vita
ancora oggi è proprio il timone
di ogni cosa e quindi anche se questo
viaggio
ad oggi
sicuramente sotto una nuova forma
esteriore la mia forma mentis e quindi
il mio modo di intendere e di
approcciare il mondo e sicuramente
rimasto uguale
e questo ritorno al desiderio
quindi al desiderio di disegnare
è sempre stato condiviso anche da tutte
le persone che dalla prima visita in
ospedale mi hanno hanno invaso la mia
stanza di sketch book
colori supporti di ogni genere
io credo che accogliendo il desiderio
tutte le cellule
si
uniscono e contribuiscono e collaborano
per raggiungere obiettivi comuni
e
[Musica]
le lesioni midollari non
danno molto tempo per rielaborare la tua
forma e impongono una riabilitazione
immediata e quindi
è molto meglio ritornare al desiderio
perché ritorniamo ad una dimensione
conosciuta e quindi la nostra esperienza
del nostro corpo deve assolutamente
modificarsi
e ritorniamo alla dimensione conosciuta
abbracciandoci e quindi
la nostra riabilitazione non è più
quella di fisiatri ma è quella che
imponiamo noi con i nostri tempi e
nostri obiettivi è proprio con questo
spirito che è nato il progetto tetra
pride
proprio con io mi chiedevo in quei
giorni di pandemia perché è nato nel
marzo 2020
mi chiedevo cosa da persona creativa
volessi raccontare della mia nuova
condizione se volesse condividere
qualcosa come
volevo raccontare di questa nuova
dimensione
quindi inizia a fare delle ricerche
per capire come venisse rappresentata
la disabilità
e decisi di
sperimentare il potere dell'immagine
perché secondo me l'immagine ha una
fortissima essi massima capacità di
raccontare situazioni e
persone senza pietismo e con la giusta
ironia
e per questo che secondo me
supportare il lavoro degli artisti
disabili e molto molto importante sia
per questa potenza dell'immagine e sia
perché avremmo modo di ampliare il
nostro immaginario
rispetto allo spettro della disabilità
che enorme
ecco secondo me l'arte riesce ad
abbattere
stereotipi muri barriere
[Musica]
proprio perché da sempre si interessa al
limite no
il limite è molto spesso il punto di
partenza dell'arte e la condizione
disabilitante ovviamente integra il
limite nella pratica artistica
del resto il fare arte proprio di ogni
essere umano
proprio perché a che fare con il
desiderio e desiderio di espressione
della propria identità il desiderio
di condividere valori
e
tanti artisti disabili stanno
ampliando questo immaginario
e soprattutto si stanno interessando di
creare una vera e propria cultura visiva
identitaria
per esempio mari katia ma
individua e
il suo lavoro come la sua forma più
grande di libertà e
[Musica]
proprio per questo io vorrei che
la forma del nostro mondo del nostro
prossimo mondo
accolga
il desiderio e rende il desiderio
accessibile a tutti
vorrei che la nostra identità venisse
sempre rappresentata che ogni essere
umano possa sentirsi felice a proprio
agio e credo che
questo possa avvenire solamente in un
mondo equo è un mondo equo è un mondo in
cui
tutti possano sentire
avvertire la possibilità di desiderare
ecco la forma che vorrei del
mondo che vorrei
non è assolutamente statica non è rigida
ma è porosa
aperta
reattiva e sensitiva rispetto ai
cambiamenti alle modificazioni
aperta alla modifica perché è un mondo
che crede nella dell'evoluzione del
miglioramento
un mondo che non renda i desideri
accessibili solamente a
anche istancabile perché noi dobbiamo
smettere di pensare a un mondo in cui
lottare ogni minuto per
affermare la nostra unicità
spero di non perdere l'occasione di
essere noi stessi
farci guidare dal desiderio e avere una
vita pienissima per realizzarli io vi
ringrazio molto
[Applauso]
[Musica]